i have a question for molly
um
so thanks for the great talk uh it it
definitely seems intuitive to me
that you can't like
have the best of all worlds you can't
achieve low regret and try to test
certain hypotheses and try you can't
have everything
but to your knowledge is there any kind
of like
simple toy example where we have some
impossibility theorem
that that would that would show us the
extent at least here theoretically it
would show us the extent to which that
cannot be
done
um no i don't have a really great
example i mean what we did when we were
running adaptive experience was just
run simulations with all of the
different hypothetical primary parameter
values that we thought about using and
then see if we could find some kind of
like frontier where we could fix the
best combination of them and we just
didn't find a really smooth nice way to
combine things to figure out like
exactly what that trade-off is
um no i think that would be a great
thing to have and i would love to have
that for illustration going forward so
if anyone has ideas about how to do that
i'd love to to think about that thank
you
thanks molly um so i just want to say a
quick uh
word about this and then also ask a
question so since this i think it's a
very confusing thing that the fact that
algorithms are optimal for regret are
not optimal for infrareds yes and the
reason why is because they give up on
any sub-optimal arms yes they give up on
precision on those lower arms very
quickly
in practice this is often not as much of
a problem as you would think because our
confidence intervals are loose anyways
so in simulation you'll always see this
issue however in practice confidence
intervals tell us to be a little bit
inflated a very quick fix actually to
just be able to use regret minimizing
algorithms to be optimal
for or to be you know within a factor of
two of doing the right thing for
inference is just inflate your
confidence bounds multiply them all by
like 1.5
and algorithms like ucp or thompson
sampling can work very effectively for
um inference and so
and the reason why is again you're just
getting the confidence bounds down and
so the the guarantee of kind of these
regret minimizing algorithms right is
that they're learning the value of the
best arm but they're maybe not learning
the identity of where that best arm is
but they're still going after that value
um very effectively
and even an algorithm just like
uniformly pulling and then eliminating
car arms that you know are bad tends to
be within a factor of two or factor of
four of the optimal
regret um so
i think this is like just facts that
about bandits people don't know but get
very confused about um in this
literature i had a question though just
about your like experimental design so
when you run this um
how big are your batches like the sample
size you're showing us in those
simulations was like a thousand but
oftentimes if your gap is very small
you you won't see an effect that quickly
so like what kind of effect sizes were
you going after and how are you handling
the fact that like one of the issues i
often have with these adaptive
algorithms is there's a lot of
non-stationarity and that
like
it's very dan even using something like
top two thousand sampling is very
dangerous if you're not somehow
adjusting for that non-stationary
because it can make bad decisions at the
beginning so yeah
that's sorry one comment and one
question but very interesting work
thanks and i think that's so helpful
thinking about the trade-off between um
regret and your inference i don't think
it's harder when you come to contextual
policies i've found that in practice
those are really hard to evaluate on
adaptively collected data and to get um
estimates to get inference that would be
comparable to even what you would get if
you had just randomly collected data
that you're often better off just you
know if you know what your policy is
that you want to evaluate you are often
better off just using randomly collected
data completely randomly as compared to
adaptively collected data even if that
adaptive algorithm is going for the same
thing that your policy is going for
there are enough problems with the
imbalance in treatment assignment
probabilities but i think that's great
and i think that's useful feedback for
me too for presenting this going forward
in terms of the non-stationarity so the
algorithm that we're using that i
presented here is not batch wise we're
doing online updating after a meaningful
first batch
um
and in practice we're getting you know
1500 or 2000 observations per concern
category for our learning where we're
just trying to learn which message is
best non-stationarity is really a
problem it's really a problem in these
settings on facebook uh i haven't
addressed it here in this talk but it's
absolutely a problem when you don't have
control over your sample then it might
be that people who are coming into your
experiments later
fundamentally look different than people
who are coming to your experiment early
on um
so i have alighted that and now you are
exposing that i have a lot of that have
not addressed it um what we do try to do
is get enough matches or get enough data
that we have
we think that we're pretty confident
that we're getting something that is
overall going to perform well and we're
not getting something that will be just
kind of pretty noisy early on and then
we do our evaluation very soon after so
we are trying to get an evaluation phase
that's very very close to our learning
phase so that there's not that much
temporal difference
there are we i haven't been using
algorithms that adjust for that uh
that type of instability i know that
there are and i think if we were running
longer adaptive experiments or we were
more concerned about getting even more
diverse samples we'd account for that um
but that's that is a really meaningful
consideration but what i basically said
is we're hoping that it's not enough big
enough of a problem in our actual
application but i really appreciate that
concern yeah
this is a question for alison um thank
you for the talk um
these kids always give me a headache in
terms of trying to figure out what
they're doing um i wonder whether you
could say a little bit more about
why you think the children are exploring
a bigger hypothesis space
than the adults so in particular what
i'm wondering is that to what extent are
they
actively or consciously exploring this
larger hypothesis space as opposed to
just doing all sorts of things and
collecting all sorts of different data
and then in the end backing out an
explanation of uh that fits the
phenomena retrospectively
yeah i mean i think this is for me this
is like the big interesting question
that's going to be
that's going to be uh
the the focus of both the ai and the
developmental work which is again i
think that's this question about how
much is random exploration and how much
is some kind of directed exploration and
we know it's not completely random in
all of these cases and in some cases
there's a paper that just came out uh
with uh
eric schultz and azura ruggieri where
you know in like a simple rl bandit task
you can you can specify whether things
are right
to what extent things are random and to
what extent things are directed and what
they found is that the younger kids do
do more random exploration now that's
where you're actually you know looking
at the policies they have not what's
going on internally in their hypothesis
uh uh sampling and what they find is
that the kids are doing both more random
and more directed exploration than the
adults are
but there does seem to be this this
developmental sequence where you start
out more random and then
move towards things that are more
directed but you're never completely
random you're always doing things that
are that are at least partly uh that are
at least partly directed and i think
it's a really interesting question about
what kind of
uh
balance and how you would achieve the
balance at a higher level between doing
a kind of random exploration and doing a
more directed
doing a more directed exploration both
when you're trying to explore the
hypothesis space and when you're
uh trying to do exploratory policies
where you're actually trying to trying
to uh
design interventions i mean in in that
blicket detector case i think one thing
that's clear is it's not that the kids
are just in fact we compared them
against a random algorithm uh and if
they're clearly not doing things that
are just random um
they're adapting depending on what the
actual structure is so they are
performing different interventions when
the actual structure is conjunctive
versus disjunctive and they're
doing different things when they get the
hypothesis space and when they don't get
the hypothesis space um but exactly what
it is that they're doing that's that's
was partly why i was thinking people
have uh people have some ideas about
that that's still sort of up for grabs
one one last thing to say uh going back
to one of the slides that i showed you
when we did that study where we looked
at the whole age range for you know from
preschoolers to to grown-ups
one possibility
is that it's not so much the kids are
searching more broadly it's just that
they have a
uh
less peaked prior they have a flatter
prior and that's an obvious possibility
and it's probably partly true so they
just don't have as much evidence for one
over hypothesis versus another one which
in itself is interesting and that would
lead them to search more broadly um but
it's kind of interesting if that was
true you'd sort of think that there
would just be a linear
uh relationship between how old you were
and how likely you were to have the
narrower uh the the narrower more peak
prior because you're getting presumably
you're getting information in a regular
fairly regular uh basis and instead what
we found was these big shifts from
preschool to school age and then from uh
school age to adolescence uh which
suggests that and we know that there are
like differences big
big neural shifts at those points which
suggest that there might be something
sort of more intrinsically different
about how the searches how the
searching's going on i don't know if i i
think that was answering your question
or at least
thank you question
um hi it's also for alison it's kind of
related to the previous question so you
mentioned and i think here as well that
one of the advantages that children
might have in exploring this space is
that they take these larger moves so
essentially they explore that space a
lot more widely perhaps than adults
would um and you mentioned that also
that might be an indication that in ai
methods perhaps
we need to be moving bigger
moves bigger proposals state like make a
step a little bit further from our data
when we are exploring the space
and i'm not working in that field but it
made me think about self-driving cars
and how i'm imagining self-driving cars
trying to make decisions that are not
whether they're trying to explore
optimal ways to drive around not solely
based on data but also based on some
form of intuition that perhaps like
similar to what children have
so and and then ethical problems come
into play about how
we're exploring the space widely
outside of the information that we have
been receiving
i just wanted to like understand what
you know if you you see any problems in
that you know imagine like a child
perhaps if you
don't like close the outlets they'll put
their finger in there because it's
dangerous but there's a little bit of a
control environment there so how are you
imagining
like us controlling
ai at the same time as letting it
explore these spaces uh better
yeah i mean i think that's a really good
question and i think again the design
the evolutionary design of development
is is an interesting
uh is an interesting kind of model so
we actually disable i mean this is going
to sound funny but like we disable our
explorers by having them be children who
are weak and can't do very much
um you know we don't you wouldn't think
about you know why is it that
two-year-olds can't take care of
themselves right i mean it would
obviously be better why are they little
why
don't they have very good executive
function why aren't they very good at
planning all of those things would seem
like problems and part of what i've
suggested is that might actually help
them in exploring but another thing that
it might do is keep them from
uh
keep them from really negative outcomes
right so if you can't do as much then
ironically that what that means is that
you can explore without uh necessarily
uh you can explore without necessarily
having to deal with the the outcomes and
then of course the other thing is that
you have that's the last part of my our
my point about social learning is that
you have grown-ups and adults who are
designed to actually be the ones who who
enable this to be a context in which you
can explore and then a last one that i
think is really interesting is kids
spend a lot of time
playing and specifically pretending and
one of the great puzzles in psychology
has always been why would you spend so
much time
thinking about things that are you know
are not true
and are far removed from any of the real
things that you're going to to have to
deal with and one thought is you could
think of that as being the equivalent of
say using your self-driving cars in
simulation um we've done some of that in
at berkeley for a long time before you
actually let them go out into the world
so you might want to think if you could
explore in the simulated environment the
way that kids are doing when they're
pretending for example then you don't
have to worry as much about some of
those ethical uh ethical and practical
uh consequences um and we actually have
a nice uh we have a very nice project
that we're doing with some of the people
at um google brain
where when robotics for example actually
letting the robot instead of the robots
imitating the intentional actions of
people having them imitate play having
them actually be trained with
uh with data that comes from play
actually means that when the robots are
implementing things they're more robust
so even though the play isn't actually
bringing about the outcomes that you
want that actually seems to be a better
way of training um and we're doing that
now with with using some of these uh vr
environments with uh with kids actually
being able to just explore a space and
then see what giving that information to
uh to a robot agent does
hi molly very interesting talk so i have
two questions my first question is like
for your online algorithm when you just
don't make the decision of what policy
we should use at the last time point um
how you make the decision based on the
counterfactual outcome at the current
time point
based on the recent past or are you just
making the decision based on some
estimated conditional um mean outcome
regressions and the second question is
like um it seems to me like the acronym
itself doesn't provide how should we
choose among different adaptive design
strategies so suppose i have two
adaptive design strategies
is there any ways that i can choose um
between between them when i say more and
more they like coming yeah that is my
question okay so let me see if i
understand your first question which is
if i rephrase it when we do our
evaluation phase how are we doing our
policy learning for the policy that
we're evaluating do we just
use
um
unadjusted estimates or do we use some
kind of doubly robust estimates where we
adjust for covariance is that the
question uh i mean like do you make the
decision based on the some counter
factors
do you still use the cultural influence
framework in that step or do you simply
use to observe the data
um
i'm not sure if i quite understand i
mean we're
we are
estimating what response would be across
our distribution
um under each of the different versions
of treatment
so in that sense yes
we're thinking about counter factuals
we're thinking about what response would
be under each of the different versions
of treatment
okay
okay and the other question was sorry
how do we compare algorithms and decide
which one is best for us um if we have
potentially two algorithms that have the
same objective that are have the same
optimization procedure i mean i don't
have a good decision rule for that i
would love if people are working on that
or have thoughts on that the way that i
would approach this would be basically
to
apply this in simulations to the
settings that i think i'm going to be
operating in and see how they perform in
finite samples because a lot of what we
know about these algorithms is
asymptotic but i would love if people
have better approaches to a decision
rule that you could give to
practitioners and say you know consider
these two alternatives and here's a good
approach to doing that that's more
structured than just trying it out and
seeing what works
um i have one question for ellison and
one for avi we'll take them separately
so
in the
exploit exploits uh trade-off that i
mean it it depends on the time horizon
right so how long we can can exploit so
a possible explanation for what you
observe could be that
adults realize that this is a very
specific environment and learning to
differentiate the rule between stripes
and dots will not carry any
utility outside of this very limited lab
experiment right
so have you looked at
altering the the time of the risen
factor and seeing if that can explain
the differences between children and
adults yeah um so one of the questions
is
one of the arguments that people that
people have made is part of the reason
why you might see this is exactly
because the time horizon when you're the
reason why you might see the early
explorer and then the later exploit is
exactly because the time horizons by
definition are different so by
definition you're going to have a longer
time horizon early on in the process
than you are
uh than you are later in the process um
my
with the the
um learning trap those particular
approachaboid experiments um i'm not
sure that actually expanding the
um
expanding the temporal window is going
to help because what happens is that
once you start committing to the
particular policy about the
avoiding
then you all the data that you're
getting is confirming what your original
hypothesis was now it could be that if
we just gave them a longer um a somewhat
longer i mean it is true in general that
with longer time horizons you see more
exploration but i think what barracus
and todd found and you know again if you
think about some of these examples in
real life like um anxiety disorders or
uh or phobias even when there's quite a
long time horizon you know even when you
think that your decisions about getting
on airplanes are going to be relevant
for many many decisions over a long time
you can get stuck in this local minimum
of
of
of avoidance so i think it is true that
the time horizon might change things but
i think what garakis at all found is
that even when you give people a longer
time horizon uh in this kind of approach
avoid context they still get stuck in
the they still get stuck in the uh in
the local minimum and you know
uh phenomenologically when people when
adults are doing this
their
um
their you know their their affect is oh
this is great i figured this out i
figured out what the hypothesis is all
the data i'm getting is completely
consistent with that so i'm doing
brilliantly and i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna keep i'm just gonna keep
going um
that makes sense yeah by the way there's
a beautiful result that i love it's one
of my favorite neuroscience results uh
when they were looking at these explore
exploit uh beckett evits looked at these
exploration point decisions in primates
where you could actually measure brain
activity and what they found was that
the decision-making parts of the brain
at the time when you were doing the um
explore uh choice so you know you then
you can very carefully say is the animal
doing the explore choice they're doing
these boat choice and they thought that
what might be happening is that you'd
see a distinctive pattern in
decision-making parts of the brain in
fact what they found is that there was
this
um uh injection of noise into the
decision-making parts of the brain so it
was as if what the brain was doing was
not saying okay i better start exploring
now because then i'll get more
information that might do me more good
in the long run it was more like what
the brain was saying was why the hell
was this this is boring let me just i'm
bored i just want to go and try
something
i'm just going to do something else
randomly and that seemed like it that
was kind of more the
more the situation but i think it's a
very very interesting question
thank you ed so we um we have talked
about this before but i'm i'm interested
in your updated view on it so these
treatment probabilities in the end of
your talk
like in many of these settings doesn't
really make sense talking about
treatment probabilities so should we see
them like how should conceptually should
we see them at representing something or
should we see them as more of a tool of
balancing
uh and in if so what do the kind of
weights the treatment assignment
probability perspective change just
yeah or bring to the table uh compared
to just looking at the like the
the raw centered control words
yeah so um no thanks for that question
uh question frederick it's um as he said
it's something we've talked about many
times over the years and
you know uh
this is something where i think
the kind of canonical synthetic control
setting really can lead to these
pathological settings so what does it
mean to talk about
the probability of west germany
reunifying
right as a propensity score
and it it's not really clear like it's
not also clear to you we would even
define that counter factual for one of
these other
countries you know what does it make
sense to say austria reunifying with
west germany like that's a release
germany right it's a
the some of these kind of factors just
don't even make sense so there's
definitely these corner cases
and you you start entering into these
kind of theological questions there
um
so
uh
lots of different ways to answer your
question more broadly right i think
there are certainly corner cases where
i'm never going to come up with a good
answer the question is okay how is this
perspective useful and i think for me
it's useful in that we're not always in
that one treated unit setting right so
in the in the case of
states adopting
uh states adopting a new policy
right we can actually imagine these as
very as valid treatment probabilities
and i think for me in terms of how to
categorize methods
it's very helpful for me to put this
side by side with say more traditional
ipw and a lot of those settings so um so
i think the first part of my answer is
when i'm not in a corner case
right um
this connection to
estimating these probability of
treatment assignment weights allows me
to
to compare synth for example to other
methods that get at those same kinds of
weights like traditional ipw so that's
one way to just kind of do apples to
apples um
i think the other part of this that is
hard is sort of a new paper i don't
think david's here
with new paper coming out at ai stats
that looks at
the role of
these um
these true propensities right or in an
ml with some type like the sometimes
we'll call this like the density ratio
that you're trying to estimate directly
and
one of the things we're finding is that
actually
in settings like
uh synthetic controls or other balancing
weights problems we kind of have this
implicit outcome model
it's actually the the line between like
a pure design-based approach and outcome
modeling is somewhat blurry
um and so it's not a satisfying answer
to your question but i think it's um
in a lot of these cases where
there's really just one treated unit we
can't necessarily conceptualize its
probability of treatment
we can we can sometimes start to think
about these balancing weight style
approaches as actually
approximating something in an outcome
model a class of outcome models and so
again i'm not taking that treatment
assignment very that probability
seriously i'm thinking that as a tool to
get it
an estimation approach
but um
it's it's tough um i will say the one
thing that we've talked about a lot that
i disagree with some others on is that
um
a common inference approach in synthetic
controls is to do a uniform permutation
across units
and setting aside these corner cases
right where we don't really know how to
reason with probability treatment in
settings where we do think that that's a
well-defined probability
then that a uniform permutation is
someone at odds with that
um with that weighted it's the know this
probability of treatment and so maybe
that's a good idea maybe it's a bad idea
maybe we just find this different but it
does mean that they're they're kind of
getting a different questions there so
sorry rambly answer because it's a big
it's a big part problem sounds like
maybe angela and i need to discuss it
more later
thank you all so much and thank you to
all the three speakers for really
wonderful talks
[Applause]
so this afternoon is for continuing
these kinds of discussions